the demand for racism continues to
outstrip supply as the world explodes
over two non-racist stories the white
house hires bizarre internet influencers
to convince people to take the coveted
vaccine and the democrats are preparing
to use climate emergency to centralize
more control i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn for peace of mind whenever
you go online visit
expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first here's your quick
reminder you're paying too much for your
cell phone bill how do i know because if
you're not with pure talk usa it is
undoubtedly true that you're spending
way too much money i want you to switch
to pure talk because pure talk could be
saving your family over 800 a year
rather than spending your money with
verizon or att or t-mobile and here's
the thing you have the same great
coverage because puretalk is on the
exact same network as one of the big
three but at a fraction of the price and
switching is as easy as switching out
your sim card you can keep your phone
keep your number or get huge discounts
on the latest iphones and androids plus
right now you can get unlimited talk
text and six gigs of data for just 30
bucks a month and if you go over on the
data they're not going to charge you for
it there's a reason pure talk is the
highest rated wireless company by
consumer affairs and why they are the
preferred wireless partner of amac from
your cell phone dial pounds 250. say ben
shapiro save an additional 50 off your
very first month that is pound 250 say
keyword ben shapiro to get started
there's no reason for you to be spending
all this money with one of the big cell
phone coverage providers when you could
be spending a fraction of that amount
getting the same coverage with pure talk
usa dial pound 250 say ben shapiro save
an additional 50
off your very first month and hundreds
of bucks down the road again that's pure
talk usa alrighty so
one of the things that has happened in
modern american culture that is so weird
is that racism has been largely
alleviated on an interpersonal level if
you look at the polls throughout the
civilized world of countries where
people say they are comfortable living
next to somebody of a different race the
united states comes in at the top of the
polls in terms of people who feel
comfortable living with somebody who is
not of the same race in terms of
tolerance for example for racial
intermarriage that sort of tolerance in
the united states is extremely
widespread and of course the united
states has black americans in positions
of power in virtually every major
industry up to and including all of the
institutions of political power
and yet and yet this is the moment of
racial reckoning in fact as race
relations got better it seems that the
push for americans to recognize that
race relations lie at the root of all of
america's evils that push got harder
in order to sustain that push in order
for americans to think about race a lot
of the time when it is very very clear
that race relations in america ought to
be seen at like a world historical high
in the united states right now
in instead of looking at the reality you
have to generate more stories of how
racism has deep and abiding roots in
american life
and so the demand for racism right a
demand that is necessary in order to
push the sort of quote unquote equity
politics the democrats push right so
much of democratic politics these days
is rooted in the notion that all
inequities must be fixed by the federal
government and this is particularly true
of racial inequities and racial
inequities can be found wherever there
is racial inequality so if a black
person underperforms a white person at
anything that is a result of the evil
american systems this is what all the
critical racial theory stuff is about
this is what all of white privilege is
about right the left push is very hard
here but to sustain that is very
difficult because most americans when
they look around at their lives they
think i'm not a racist nobody i know is
a racist i wouldn't hang out with a
racist i don't like doing business with
racists so
where is all of the racism in american
society and so what the left has to do
is they make two separate arguments one
is the systems and institutions
themselves are racist which is extremely
difficult that's a difficult argument to
make when again racism in practice has
been federally illegal since 1965.
okay so that makes it a very difficult
argument and the other thing that they
do is they find these sort of outlying
stories and then they try to turn them
into examples of deep and abiding
american racism and very often these
stories just do not wash
so for example
the there was a there was a case that
happened
not all that long ago you'll remember it
in which a white woman was walking her
dog in central park
and she was confronted by a black man
who apparently wanted her to leash her
dog she had not least her dog and he got
kind of aggressive with her and she
called the cops and she said there's an
african-american man who is being
aggressive with me and he filmed her
doing this and she became the face of
white american racism right she was a
karen well as it turns out according to
national review this was not the entire
story
barry weiss reported this over at her
sub stack kamela foster also has
reported on this
okay as kyle smith sums up new yorker
amy cooper was walking her dog in
central park's ramble area a little
patch of semi-wilderness in an otherwise
manicured park she allowed her dog off
off the leash which is against the rules
on the other hand the ramble is the one
little frequency spot in the entire vast
park where it kind of sword it seems
like the rules don't apply for decades
the rules definitely didn't apply it was
a popular gay pickup location for
connoisseurs of anonymous alfresco facts
on memorial day cooper a middle-aged
white woman was allowing her dog to run
off leash breaking a rule that is widely
ignored albeit crucial for bird watchers
nearby was christian cooper a
middle-aged black man of no relation to
her mr cooper is an avid birder and
doesn't much like dogs interfering with
his avian observations so he issued what
to her sounded like a threat to poison
her dog miss cooper freaked out who
wouldn't as her freakout was underway mr
cooper filmed toronto's flown
and covington 2.0 as kyle smith puts it
like covington catholic as in the fake
news story suggesting that a bunch of
high school kids were racist when they
weren't covington 2 was off and running
the public viewed the conveniently
edited video more than 30 million times
ms cooper was denounced as a karen or
self-appointing whistleblower for her
understandable reaction and few noticed
that the inciting karen of the affair
was not the middle-aged white lady but
mr cooper himself for busting her over
allowing her dog off leash her employer
not only fired her but far worse
publicly bland branded her a racist
news accounts have repeatedly
characterized cooper as having
threatened mr cooper that is the
opposite of what happened we know this
because of mr cooper's helpful facebook
post on the matter from which i quote
me quote look if you're going to do what
you want i'm going to do what i want but
you're not going to like that her what's
that me to the dog come here puppy her
he won't come to you me we'll see about
that i pull out the dog treat i carry
for just such intransigence
possibly it was an overreaction for
cooper to call the police then again
when citizens feel threatened calling
the cops and letting them sort it out is
what is supposed to happen what cooper
said to her was unmistakably a threat it
was reasonable for her to be scared
it was a menacing thing to say he then
called the dog over while offering it a
treat he meant her to think he was going
to poison her dog to motivate her to
leash the animal by his own admission he
said something calculated to frighten
her apparently he does this all the time
he carries dog treats while birding for
quote just such intransigence if there
were no threat linked to his offering
dog a snack he would not have prefaced
this action by saying you're not going
to like it
miss cooper probably would have been
wise to leash her pet and walk briskly
away but when a stranger threatens to
poison your dog in central park that's
bound to cause consternation it's not
unreasonable for her to have felt
herself personally threatened by
cooper's saying i'm gonna do what i want
and you're not gonna like it
she later told cnn i didn't know what
that meant when you're alone in a wooded
area that's absolutely terrifying right
okay the fact is that what cooper said
to the police was accurate and people
started calling her a racist pretty much
right afterward and then her financial
firm tweeted out that she was a racist
okay but this sort of incident you
remember this this was like a big
national story that a woman called the
cops on a black man and said that he was
black to the cops you remember this
okay well
those kinds of stories have become
increasingly common in american life it
is why the press feel the need to jump
on obviously suspicious story like the
jessie smolyer's story
and when jesse smilet
announced that he was attacked by two
vicious red-hatted white men who tried
to string him up in the middle of
chicago's downtown at 4 00 a.m in a
windstorm and the entire media decide
and by the way kamal harris and the rest
of the democratic party decided this was
a major national story the reason for
that is because demand for racism
outstrips supply at this point okay we
now have a couple more stories along
these lines so over the last 24 hours
the colorado rockies decided that it was
necessary to
investigate a man who supposedly was
shouting the n-word at miami marlins
outfielder louis brinson during his
at-bat
according to the new york post quote
this is the original story rocky's
investigating after fan hurls racial
slur at marlins player okay from that
headline you would determine that the
fan was hurling a racial slur at the
marlins player after all that is the
entire headline and in fact
people were tweeting this thing out
including blue check marks
the colorado rockies put out a statement
saying the colorado rockies are
disgusted at the racial slur by a fan
directed at the marlins lewis brinson
during the ninth inning of today's game
although the subject was not identified
prior to the end of the game the rockies
are still investigating this incident
the rockies have zero tolerance for any
form of racism or discrimination and any
fan using derogatory language of any
kind will be ejected and barred from
coors field
okay and uh and then a statement was put
out by the
major league baseball players
association executive director and
former yankee tony clark he said it is a
painful reality that progress continues
to be elusive in a world where ignorance
and bigotry remain all too commonplace
okay so again this is always the idea is
that one instance of racism means that
everybody is racist and racism still
runs right throughout american life that
in and of itself is really stupid an
isolated incident is isolated and
noteworthy because it is isolated and
also noteworthy
okay an isolated incident if it is
indicative of broad national trends
generally is not isolated and you can
name many instances of this sort of
stuff happening but this was a national
story literally one person supposedly
shouting the n word at a baseball player
you had the major league baseball
players association commenting on this
you had major league baseball itself
commenting on this yeah the colorado
rockies commenting on all this okay then
the rockies started to do an
investigation
and what they found is that the man was
not in fact shouting the n-word in fact
here is the video of the man not
shouting the n-word he is not shouting
the n-word here he is shouting at the
kalo rock he's the colorado rockies
mascot whose name is dinger
okay he's shouting at the mascot
here's what the tape sounded like
three yesterday here's the 1-0
and again it's 2-0 and this is not to
pick on
okay he's not shouting the n-word he's
shouting dinger dinger that's the name
of the team's mascot
a denver news reporter this is the new
york post the next day right walking it
back a denver news reporter who spoke to
the rockies organization said the team
interviewed the fan about the incident
the rockies tell me last night's
incident was a fan shouting to get the
attention of the rocky's mascot dinger
not a racial slur the rockies have
spoken to the fan who confirms this is
the case they've also reviewed the video
from the local broadcast
so
a lot of people again in the blue
checkmark world had decided this was
indicative of major league baseball fans
more generally or america more generally
but as it turns out that wasn't the
story at all and now the colorado
rockies had to put out an update on this
in which they admitted that the fan was
indeed yelling for rocky's mascot dinger
in hopes of getting his attention for a
photo and there was never any racial
slur that occurred
the rockies remain dedicated to
providing an inclusive environment for
all fans players in gas at coors field
and any fan using derogatory language of
any kind will be ejected from coors
field okay well thank you for that
meaningless notification considering
that nobody said anything racist
okay this was a massive national story
it was a major national story
that people were a guy was supposedly
yelling the n-word at a black baseball
player when he was in fact not and that
was not the only story that is like this
cnn reports today quote a rock that
students call a symbol of racism has
been removed from university of
wisconsin okay now you may notice that
there's a little bit of hedging in that
particular title right a rock that
students call a symbol of racism so is
the rock a symbol of racism or is the
rock not a symbol of racism well as it
turns out the rock is absolutely not a
symbol of racism in fact there is pretty
much no evidence that the rock was ever
a symbol of racism according to cnn
itself the university of wisconsin
removed a 42-ton boulder from its
madison campus on friday after
complaints from students of color who
called the rock a symbol of racism
chamberlain rock which had sat on
observatory points since 1925 was named
after thomas chamberlain
a geologist and former university
president who served from 1887 to 1892.
so um what's racist about that was
thomas chamberlain a vicious slave
holding racist or something
nope there was one article from the
wisconsin state journal in 1925 that
used the n-word as part of a nickname
for the giant boulder
that's the whole thing
an article they use the n-word and a
nickname for the rock
and now they spent i kid you not 50
to remove a 42-ton boulder for no reason
other than apparently students of color
at the university of wisconsin are
offended by a rock
that is not racist
because it's a rock that is not racist
the wisconsin black student union last
summer called for the rock to be removed
from campus as one of a series of
demands it said were aimed at seeking
justice for black students the campaign
came in the wake of the police killings
of george floyd and brianna taylor
senior nala mcquarter said in a
university news release quote it was
very meaningful for me to be there and
to see the process all the way through
to the end
mcquarter who was the president of
wisconsin black student union for the
past academic year was there when the
boulder was removed on friday quote it
was about a year ago that we released
our demands and met with the chancellor
and explained to her why those demands
meant so much to us it was a powerful
moment today to see this demand come
full circle
amazing
amazing by the way the rock also had to
be removed because a native american
student organization named wonk
chic partnered with the wisconsin black
student union in the rock removal effort
because the boulder sat on ancestral ho
chunk land
the university actually had to get
permission from the wisconsin historical
society to remove the boulder because it
sat within the area of a native american
burial mound according to the university
so they moved the rock because nothing
because literally nothing like there's
no evidence that the rock is racist
nobody sees the rock as racist
it's a rock it's a rock
like literally the the most they can say
is that an article from about a hundred
years ago used the n-word while
referring to the rock
the chancellor's office is using private
donations to pay the 50 000 price tag
for the rock's removal the university
said it's now being moved to university
on land near lake kagansa southeast of
madison first of all i don't think
that's appropriate i think this rock has
to go directly in the lake right i mean
it's a racist rock just removing it to
another piece of land doesn't that make
that piece of land racist i've been
reliably informed that according to as
james lindsey says critical rock theory
this rock is a is a foundation stone for
systemic racism so just moving it to
another piece of land somewhere isn't
going to do it it must be buried deep
under actually we can't even bury it
deep underground we need to shoot it
into the sun
that is the only way to cleanse this
planet of racism
this rock some some idiot in 1925 use
the n-word to refer to the rock the only
way to solve this problem is to
build the world's largest trebuchet and
fire the rock into orbit hopefully out
of orbit hopefully it doesn't even stay
like orbiting the planet it needs to go
we need to chisel this thing down to
sand that's the other possibility
we all every white person in america
owes a duty to go with a chisel and a
hammer and chisel this giant rock down
to sand
only then will racism be alleviated in
the united states if you're getting the
feeling that um people are lazy and
stupid in the united states and that
they spend a lot of time worrying about
things that really ought not be worried
about that would be correct
that our media are too lazy and stupid
to actually investigate the true stories
of these things and if they do they are
too pusillanimous to actually stand up
and say wait a second you're telling me
that somebody's supposed to spend 50
grand to move a giant ass rock because
somebody called it a racist term a
hundred years ago are you out of your
mind
the answer of course is yes everybody is
out of their mind
as we'll examine when it comes to covet
in just one second first let us talk
about your sleep quality so as you may
have noticed i am on the road that means
i am not sleeping as well as i normally
sleep i mean let's be frank you know i
have said publicly
that i sleep in a bed made of money
that's not quite true the bed made of
money that i have in my house it turns
out it's not particularly comfortable
instead i prefer to sleep on my helix
sleep mattress because that was made
just for me and it's more conducive to
sleep you know money it's kind of hard
but i will say that the helix sleep
mattress is just perfect it's like
sleeping on a cloud helix sleep has a
quiz that takes just two minutes to
complete and matches your body type and
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you why would you buy a
mattress made for someone else with
helix you're getting a mattress you know
will be perfect for the way you sleep
everybody's unique helix knows that so
they have several different mattress
models to choose from they've soft
medium and for mattresses mattresses
great for cooling you down if you sleep
hot even a helix plus mattress for plus
size folks so if you're looking for a
mattress you take the quiz you order the
mattress you're matched to the mattress
comes right to your doorship for free
you don't ever need to go to a mattress
store again helix is awesome you don't
need to take my word for it he looks
rewarded the number one best overall
mattress pick of 2020 by both gq and
wired magazine
head on over to helixsleep.com ben take
their two minutes sleep quiz they will
match you to a customized mattress
that'll give you the best sleep of your
life they've got a 10 year warranty you
get to try it out for 100 nights risk
free they'll even pick it up for you if
you don't love it but you will so go
check them out right now helix is
offering up to 200 bucks off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners that is a great offer at
helixsleep.com again
helixsleep.com for a great deal on a
great mattress and the two free pillows
and the 200 bucks off i mean what more
could you ask for alrighty so meanwhile
speaking of people losing their absolute
ever-loving mind
the white house has now decided that it
is necessary to team up with tick-tock
stars tick-tock stars to encourage
people to get vaccinated because if
there is one group of people that i
would say
rural trump voters love it is tick-tock
stars love them they are so into it now
the white house is spending real money
on this according to the new york times
just a couple of days ago ellie zeiler17
a tick tock creator with over 10 million
followers received an email in june from
village marketing an influencer
marketing agency it said it was reaching
out on behalf of another party the white
house would miss zeiler a high school
senior who usually posts short fashion
and lifestyle videos be willing the
agents he wanted to participate in a
white house backed campaign encouraging
her audience to get vaccinated against
the coronavirus
ms zeiler quickly agreed joining a broad
personality driven campaign to confront
an increasingly urgent challenge in the
fight against the pandemic vaccinating
the youthful masses who have the lowest
inoculation rates of any eligible age
group in the united states
the white house has enlisted an eclectic
army of more than 50 twitch streamers
youtubers tic tackers and the 18 year
old pop star olivia rodrigo all of them
with enormous online audiences
by the way i would love to see a study
to see
how much it costs like for each
vaccination how much is this actually
costing
that i think would be uh fascinating to
see okay here is uh we now have
the greatest example of vaccine
messaging i have ever seen courtesy of
the white house and it is just
spectacular i mean it is
unparalleled in its in its wonder i
don't know who this youtube influencer
is this tick tock influencer frankly i
don't really want to know i guess this
is a person i'm looking up right now
it's a person named benny drama
which sounds just spectacular according
to the uk daily mail benito skinner a
comedian whose tick-tock handle is benny
drama he boasts over 845 000 followers
posted a video on monday which featured
a day in my life as a white house intern
the video is also posted to instagram
and twitter as well
and um
here is um
here is a little bit of the video that
your tax dollars get to pay for
hi my name is cooper and this is a day
in my life as a white house intern
we did a joke
hey everyone
this is actually the entrance to the
west wing this is so fun and it's really
prestigious hey potus is olivia
rodriguez still here
no we've come a long way in our fight
against this virus we've vaccinated 160
million americans are you getting this
all down don't worry queen all right
here
uh
he
in and then and then what what in the
actual
what was that
what no
so yeah
when we're talking about the groups
least likely to be vaccinated in america
by poll statistics it is people who
identify as republicans
and black and hispanic americans
i'm just wondering
is this benny drama character like super
popular among either rural trump voters
and tucker carlson watchers or
black americans living in the inner city
like who's the who's the core audience
for benny drama
and
his her sure
i don't want to assume anybody's gender
here i i have no idea i guess i guess he
identifies as he so i'm i can that's
exciting actually frankly i'm excited
because i knew that was a man so now
that i get to say that that's a man
that's exciting that that's the society
we now live in so i can say he without
being banned on twitter or facebook
that's exciting so he apparently uh wear
donning his skirt and also long white
nails and making ridiculous jokes with
gensake that is going to uh that's going
to convince millions of people to get
vaccinated as well also you will notice
that neither this person nor gensake are
wearing masks
yes well in close proximity with one
another apparently the video was filmed
on july 12th the white house official
july 20th rather a white house official
told the daily mail before the mask
requirements were reinstated
just spectacular
that that's this is great again i'm so
glad i'm sorry our country's so stupid
like we are
we're beyond the point of of
return i think i think we may be done
i think it's time whoever last person
now turn out the lights like don't don't
run up the electricity bills because
we're toast like we got a real problem
what should convince you to get a
vaccine is a pretty simple fact which is
that for virtually everybody in the
united states the chances of getting
covered and then dying from covert are
significantly higher than the chances of
getting a serious adverse effect and
dying from a vaccine
that's true for pretty much everyone as
far as the data are concerned
that seems like that should be a better
argument than
here is a strange person from tiktok
posing with gensake and making bizarre
jokes about vaccines while wearing fake
nails
and wearing a skirt
and doing things that no one understands
yeah but
uh
there's a point at which words simply
fail and i think we we may have reached
that point alrighty in just one second
we'll get to more places where words
should fail namely the bizarre
overreactions in which we are now
engaging first let's talk about making
your hiring process better so a lot of
businesses are in rush to hire employees
right now because demand is going back
up people are getting back to work
despite everybody freaking them out over
covet and that means a lot of places
that need to hire but if you're looking
to hire it can be hard to find the right
person well all these businesses
reopening it means millions of jobs will
need to be filled so where do those
businesses turn to fill those roles fast
ziprecruiter right now you can try it
for free at ziprecruiter.com
wire when you post a job on zip
recruiter they send your job to over 100
top job sites giving you access to their
network of millions of job seekers zip
recruiters matching technology scans
resumes to find qualified candidates for
your open roles and then proactively
presents them to you you can easily
review recommended candidates and invite
your top choices to apply for your job
which encourages them to apply faster
according to zip recruiter internal data
jobs where employers invite candidates
to apply get two and a half times more
candidates zip recruiters technology is
so effective that four out of five
employers who post on zip recruiter get
a quality candidate within the very
first day and right now you can try zip
recruiter for free at this exclusive web
address zip recruiter dot com slash
daily wire again that is
ziprecruiter.com d-a-i-l-y-w-i-r-e
zip recruiter dot com slash dailywire
zip recruiter is the smartest way to
hire alright so all over the world
people seem to be losing their ever
loving minds when it comes to the
coveted policies that they seek to use
the reality is this delta is basically
skunking every place where people are
indoors and in anywhere close to close
proximity end of story right we're
seeing spikes in israel where a huge
number of people are already vaccinated
you're seeing spikes in australia where
everybody is still locked down
and yet the covet experts keep telling
us that they have a solution i just
don't know what their solution is like
what is their solution
the solution was supposed to be the
vaccine the solution remains the vaccine
because all those people who are
vaccinated the vast vast vast majority
of them will not die by current data
99.99 of people who get the vaccine will
not die of covid that is the current
data
the vaccines are incredibly effective
and yet we are being told that if we
don't ask our children that if we don't
mask ourselves that if we don't
initiate social distancing measures
again and shut down businesses again
then covet is going to kill us all and
this is a transnational thing i don't
want to paint it like it's just in
america i think it obviously is not in
fact video emerged just today from paris
where the police are literally checking
the papers the vaccination people's
papers of people who are sitting outside
and eating outside and eating by the way
the paranoia is real i mean i'm in los
angeles right now
because the mask mandates a huge number
of people are walking around with masks
but i'm seeing people who are walking
around vaccinated outside wearing n95s i
am not kidding you i've talked to some
of them
and the reason that they're doing this
is because they're convinced that the
vaccines don't work in preventing
serious disease and they've been
convinced of that by the irresponsible
media who keep lying to them and trying
to scare the living hell out of them
and it is not true
available data from israel suggests that
even when there are vaccine
breakthroughs they generally result in
extremely mild manifestations of
symptoms if you're unvaccinated it might
kill you
if you're not vaccine if you are
vaccinated there's a far lower chance
that it's going to kill you by the way
even for the unvaccinated the chances
are that it's not going to kill you i
mean by the by the
this is true even in the middle of the
pandemic right the death rate for people
who are in the oldest age bracket was
like five percent okay that's not a
chance you'd want to take but it is
certainly not the vast majority of
people who get the disease die
in any case these sorts of measures are
insane so in paris again we now have
video of people literally checking
papers
the police are just walking up and down
the street and they're literally just
checking people's papers
i mean i find that disquieting don't you
that doesn't seem great especially
because again in a free country people
should not be checking your papers to
determine whether or not you've gotten a
shot in your arm this is madness at this
point okay and then you have the people
in the united states who are pushing for
mass mandates on children
these data that they are using to do
this are extraordinarily skimpy in fact
they're essentially non-existent
you're hearing the cdc say things like
well maybe the delta variants is more
damaging to kids they have no
information they have presented publicly
that demonstrates that there's more
damage being done to kids by the delta
variant than by other variants of the of
the of covid
it has a wider spread than other
variants of covet but there is no
evidence that it is doing
disproportion and damage as opposed to
the other strains of covid
okay and yet we are being told that this
is going to damage kids and the reason
that we're being told it's going to
damage kids is because they can't scare
the adult enough so the idea is if we
cannot scare the adults enough then
we're going to have to mask up the kids
and there's a sentiment that is set in
in the big cities i was talking to a
friend who lives in new york today a
conservative friend who was in new york
and he was very very upset with the
unvaccinated in his city he's saying
this is insane they're forcing me to
mask up they're forcing me to to
wear a mask when i go into public places
they're they're creating vaccine
passports and all of this they're
masking out my kids at school all
because of the people who won't
vaccinate and what i said to him is no
it's them
the problem here is not being vaccinated
listen i disagree with many of the
people who are not vaccinating i think
that they are making a poor public
health decision and a poor decision for
themselves but
this is a free country and you get to
make those sorts of individual decisions
because again it is a free country the
real problem in the big cities is that
we have become accustomed to political
actors
turning one segment of the population
against another segment of the
population for purposes of control
you would not care as a vaccinated
person about the unvaccinated person who
lives near you except that the public
health official is using the
unvaccinated person's very presence as a
rationale for shutting down your life
so you have two choices you can get mad
at the public health officials or you
can get mad at the unvaccinated
you can be angry at both i suppose
that's a possibility but if you are
going to prioritize who to be angry at
the controlling people who suggest that
you need to mask up to protect
unvaccinated people who by the way are
not asking for protection from you
is insane those are the people you
should be upset with
former cdc director robert redfield
admitted today that there's pretty much
no data for school mass mandates at this
point and yet again the entire media
infrastructure says that if you say that
you don't want mass mandates at schools
that if you ban mass mandates like ron
desantis does in florida this means that
you are
in favor of covid you want kovid to
spread and you want people to die this
is so ridiculous i'm sorry it's
ridiculous on his face here's the former
cdc director robert redfield admitting
there's no data for school mass managed
by the way this follows hard on dr
michael osterhome former
biden advisor on covet announcing that
cloth masks don't do very much against
the delta variant
these policies should be grounded in
data
as opposed to opinion
i think
your guest raises a very important part
there's been very few studies that
really are compelling in that setting of
the classroom
we did a number of studies when i was
there just in fixed settings to
recognize that if you
uh aerosolize virus through a mask and
then the recipient had a mask and these
were all dummies in rooms that were
ventilated to a different degree you
could have an impact on the amount of
virus that went from one to another but
that's not to say in a real life
scenario that that's efficacious in the
classroom that is correct what redfield
is saying is correct the only studies
that suggest that masks are effective
really for the general public are
studies that have not taken place in the
general public right there are studies
that have to do with you fire virus at a
mask and the mask is on a dummy right
that is not quite the same thing as how
you and your friends operate the mask
because you take them off you put them
back on you breathe all over them you
take them off you put them in your
pocket you put them back on right like
that is not the same thing
okay but even put that aside
the evidence suggests that children in
school are not at significant risk of
dying from covet or even getting
seriously ill from coven on an odds
level now again when you're talking odds
somebody wins the lottery every year
right that does not mean that the odds
are in your favor if you buy a lottery
ticket well somebody will probably die
of covet in the younger age group that
does not mean that the odds are in favor
of many many people dying of covid as a
share
this is why stats matter but again this
is all a propagandistic effort to scare
the living hell out of people and take
control this is why you've got the cnn
medical analyst liana wen who is having
the time of her life man no one had
heard of this lady before covet and now
she's on cnn every day saying it's very
upsetting that gop governors are not
allowing families to protect their
children that is a lie it is a lie you
are allowed to send your kid to school
in florida wearing a mask you are the
schools are just not allowed to mandate
that everybody else wear a mask that's
not the same thing
if you want to give kids the ability to
choose whether or not to wear a kn95 at
school fine i'm all for it
but i don't think that you should be
able to force any of the other kids to
mask up
yeah but here's leanna when saying that
is it that it's upsetting that she knows
how to like again the implication here
is that our experts know how to shut
down the vipers so then why aren't you
doing it i also noticed by the way that
the number one case leader in states in
the united states is not florida it is
louisiana but you don't seem to give two
dams about louisiana there are two
reasons why they don't want to mention
louisiana one is because the governor of
louisiana is john bel edwards who's a
democrat and the other is because in
louisiana the white population is
a little bit more vaccinated than the
black population and louisiana happens
to be an extremely heavily minority
state so they don't want to mention that
because again that's rather
uncomfortable you're only supposed to
talk about anti-vaccine if the
anti-vaccine is among white people
you're not supposed to talk about
anti-vaccinating if you are talking
about people who are of minority descent
the racial composition of louisiana is
about 33 black by the way 32-33 black in
any case here's cnn cnn medical analyst
liana wen trying to blame gop governors
for all of this
i find it i think a lot of us in public
health are so frustrated that at this
point we now have the tools but there
are governors leaders in these parts of
the country that are saying we don't
want to use the tools at our disposal in
fact we're not even going to allow
families to use these tools at their
disposal to protect their children and
that's extremely upsetting especially
because we know how dangerous this delta
variant is
okay again this this sort of panic
stuff is is really ridiculous it's
really ridiculous by the way the stats
in louisiana for those who are wondering
is that only about 37
of louisiana's population has been fully
vaccinated at this point compared to
well over 50 percent at this point of
the of the eligible certainly
of the eligible population way over 50
percent in in florida including 90 of
seniors in florida have already been
vaccinated
none of this is about reason and you can
tell it's not about reason because you
can see the policies that are now being
presented okay so reason magazine has a
fascinating piece by robbie sowoff
talking about washington dc he says this
quote last week washington dc mayor
muriel bowser reinstated a citywide mass
mandate for all indoor spaces even
though the city's recent uptick in
coveted 19 cases has not yet produced a
rash of deaths or hospitalizations and
even though the vaccines are proving to
be the most remarkably effective tool at
preventing severe disease and death
masks unlike the vaccine are a perpetual
irritation especially in certain
circumstances like conversing eating and
exercising on that last front a
coalition of washington dc gym owners
decided to approach the city with a
bargain they would require customers to
be vaccinated if the city would grant
them a waiver from the mass mandate
so they said listen right now
we are open for business but you have to
wear a mask when you come in
we don't want people to have to mask
when they come in because as it turns
out working out with a mask is really
uncomfortable i know because i did it
for months it's really really
uncomfortable and so they said we don't
want you to have to wear a mask when you
come into the gym and so instead here is
our deal
we will not tell everybody to mask but
we will mandate that everybody in here
is vaccinated because one thing that we
know is that if you got a bunch of
vaccinated people with other vaccinated
people there is not this tremendous risk
that you're going to get a huge outbreak
and washington dc rejected it they
basically said we would rather do you
have a bunch of unma unvaccinated and
vaccinated people mixing with cloth
masks in a gym
than a vaccine passport okay now i don't
like the vaccine passport and i also
don't like the mass mandates i think
they're both stupid i think they're
counter-productive at this point but
if you're looking at a rational policy
the gym's policy makes perfect sense dc
wouldn't accept that
dc wouldn't accept that
and the reason of course they couldn't
accept that is because
if they did they would be acknowledging
that vaccines are more effective than
the masks which we which would be to
acknowledge that in the end people are
going to have to make decisions about
vaccines not about masks and that no
matter what you try to do with masks
it's never going to be enough
but this is the whole point it's amazing
how many people are willing to
sublet their judgment to some sort of
expert no matter who the expert is like
they never seem to bother to ask whether
the expert ought to provide data at some
point
my favorite story of this by the way is
that uh there is a person named eric
feigl ding who has become one of the
sort of coveted experts on twitter a
supposed coven 19 expert on twitter it
turns out that um at the beginning of
2020 according to jordan shachtel
writing for dossier.substance.com
at the beginning of 2020 feigl ding was
an unpaid visiting scientist in
harvard's nutrition department his
academic research centered entirely
around nutrition diet and exercise
feigl ding an inspiring politician
appeared to see an opening to influence
the masses and build up his brand when
the coveted pandemic began to make waves
and so he started to talk a lot about
covid at 19. his frequent use of harvard
associated credentials to elevate his
baseless covenanting proclamations
greatly upset some of his own colleagues
and landed him in hot water with harvard
twitter decided to credential him for no
reason at all as the covet 19 health
expert
in mid-march mark lipsich a professor of
epidemiology at harvard described him as
quote a charlatan exploiting a tenuous
connection for self-promotion
the association of healthcare
journalists also took notice reporting
he has precisely zero experience in
infectious diseases
he's departed from harvard ever since
okay so um this guy is still trotted out
as though he is some sort of expert on
covet 19. so when people tell you to
listen to the experts your first
question should be not who are the
experts it should be
what is the evidence that they are
providing at this point but
you know the tenant there's a tendency
in the human brain to maximize risk
perception because this is how humans
have survived for
so long as a species is that we have
very very active risk centers in our
brain and so anytime those are activated
we tend to immediately say whoever can
protect us we will give power to and
that is what we are doing right now
already coming up we'll see this is why
the left is declaring a climate
emergency they're trying to trigger
those panic centers in your brain so you
give them utter control over everything
except having to do with climate we'll
get to that in a moment first let us
talk about a simple fact if you run a
business and you're not using text
messages you are missing out okay let's
be real if you get a call from a
telemarketer how often are you picking
up that call the answer is pretty much
never but if you get a text from
somebody you at least check the text and
you read it and if it's from a business
you know sometimes you reply well podium
makes doing business as easy as sending
a text because when the texts get opened
business gets done all your employees
can text from a single inbox offering a
smoother experience for your customers
answering questions send a text
collecting reviews send a text
scheduling an appointment or delivery
send a text payment collection you can
just send a text card dealerships are
selling more cars by offering text
messaging a dealer just sold a 50 000
truck and four text messages for example
retailers are increasing revenue by
allowing customers to shop via text
message even with stores open many
people still want to shop from home a
jeweler just sold a 5 000 ring with a
few text messages and even coordinated
curbside pickup with podium today's
customers expect on-demand everything
even from local businesses stay ahead of
the competition with podium they've got
free plans for growing businesses plus
all the power growing businesses need to
scale get started free today at
podium.com shapiro that's podium.com
shapiro alrighty in just a moment we'll
get to the democrats declaring a climate
emergency
always always emergencies emergencies
are always the solution first let me
remind you that as the authoritarians
take control as they attempt to control
everything from whether your kid must
mask to whether you should be socially
ostracized we are living in the
authoritarian moment and it needs to be
stopped the only way to stop it is to
know how things got this bad and how to
reverse it this is why i wrote the book
the authoritarian moment it's a massive
national bestseller it is now available
at amazon barnes and noble or any other
major bookseller go get your copy right
now leave a five star review if you like
what you read the authoritarian moment
is happening right now the only way to
fight back pick up a copy of the book
the authoritarian moment check it out
right now at any place that sells books
candace owens also isn't afraid to say
what she is thinking that is for certain
if you're craving extra of her
controversial hot takes i've got good
news for you you now have a chance to
meet her and hear her opinions live and
in her studio audience if you sign up
now as a daily wire member with code vip
you get 25 off your new membership and
you can be automatically entered for a
chance to win a trip for two to the
daily wire studios in nashville to see
candace live not only will you meet
candace herself you'll be getting an
inside look at her studio and front row
seats to watch her destroy the left's
insidious ideology on her talk show
candace so get a great new deal on a new
daily wear membership at dailywire.com
subscribe with code vip and 25 off so
you can be automatically entered to win
a chance to win the vip experience also
if you're a daily wear member and a
candace owns fan i've got even more
great news for you you can now purchase
tickets to come to the daily wear
studios in nashville tennessee and see
her show live however the catch you have
to be an all access member so i get
these emails all the time how can i get
a ticket to candice's show you first
have to be a member if you are your
lovely face might even make it on screen
hurry though tickets have sold out for
every show seating is limited go get
your tickets right now they are going
fast if you live in the nashville area
or if you want to take a trip here which
is totally worth it because downtown
nashville is super cool now is the time
head on over to dailywire.com tickets
today pick up your tickets to candace's
show you're listening to the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
well meanwhile the government of the
united states democrats particularly
they need an excuse for why they're
about to spend more money than has ever
been printed in the history of humanity
we've already spent seven trillion
dollars last year we're probably gonna
spend six seven trillion dollars this
year democrats of course are moving
forward with some i would say rather
soft-headed republicans on this
infrastructure deal a one trillion
dollar infrastructure package which
contains some useful things and an awful
lot of crap according to the new york
times the legislation is expected to
pass after nearly 70 senators voted to
advance it late on sunday night
and is the product of weeks of intense
negotiations largely led by white house
officials and a core group of 10
republican and democratic senators but
without unanimous agreements who
expedite the process the bill might not
pass until tuesday morning because
senate rules require 30 hours of debate
meanwhile the democrats are trying to
ram through this 3.5 trillion dollar
package this is a 3.5 trillion dollar
budget that they are seeking to push
forward
there's no measure to raise the debt
limit
they began their push on monday
according to the new york times for the
most significant expansion of the
nation's social safety net since the
great society of the 1960s unveiling a
budget blueprint that would spend 3.5
trillion dollars on health care child
and elder education and climate change
the budget
resolution which senate democrats hope
to pass by the end of the week would
allow the caucus to piece together
social policy legislation this fall paid
for by raising taxes on the wealthy
large inheritances and corporations and
if democrats and their two independent
allies can hold together that measure
could pass the senate without a
republican vote nullifying the
filibuster threat that measure would
pass after a separate 1 trillion
bipartisan infrastructure bill likely
clears the senate on tuesday together
they would secure the remainder of
president biden's 4 trillion economic
agenda but the 2-step effort will test
it biden's ability to both work with
republicans and maneuver around them
because here's the problem at the same
time that biden is pushing forward this
1 trillion infrastructure package is
pushing for the 3.5 trillion budget
package it looks an awful lot as those
stuff that didn't make it into the
bipartisan bill makes it into the
completely partisan bill and so the
question becomes why republicans should
sign on to the bipartisan bill knowing
that all the stuff they don't vote for
is simply going to end up in that other
bill
okay for their part democrats are over
the moon about this thing this bill
spends an awful lot of money on a bunch
of crap
a huge amount on global warming oriented
nonsense you know subsidies for building
electric car charging stations and such
and or subsidies to green boondoggle
businesses all of barack obama chuck
schumer says this is deeply necessary
because climate change is actually worse
than kova 19. now anybody who says they
should be laughed out of the room
seriously this line that climate change
is worse than kova 19 has killed
probably in excess of 4 million people
worldwide
i would say likely in excess of more
than 5 million people worldwide because
i think china lies about its numbers but
even if china's not lying it's certainly
in excess of 3 million probably at this
point closer to an excess of 4 million
people worldwide if the suggestion is
that climate change is worse than that
i'm going to need some piece of evidence
to show that that's the case because
that's just not true but here's again
the goal here for democrats is claim a
thing as an emergency and then you never
actually have to come to grips with why
we should give you ultimate power
just as right now covet is no longer an
emergency you know why because an
emergency implies there's no solution we
know the solution to the coveted
emergency get yourself vaccinated if you
don't it's your problem
in the same way that people flying
through their windshields during car
accidents that's not an emergency you
have a seat belt either use it or don't
use it
okay but chuck schumer has to declare
that climate change is worse than kobe
19 so the panic centers of our amygdala
go off and suddenly we go okay fine
we'll give this doofus from new york all
total control here's chuck schumer
we're going to confront the generational
challenge of climate change head on
we're not flinching we're not wincing
we're going right at it
and as bad as covet was this year and it
was horrible
five or ten years from now every year
the climate the
climate change
will make things worse and worse and
worse even worse than it was this year
in covid
because when climate changes it's such
an overwhelming force
that unless we do something now we may
not be able to stop it okay that is not
okay it is not an overwhelming force it
isn't climate change is a gradual
warming of the climate over the course
of the next hundred years in fact this
has been happening for several decades
and you know what's been happening
people have been adapting to it because
people are excellent at adaptation we
suck at mitigation and we are great at
adaptation mitigation is stopping the
thing that leads to climate change
adaptation is dealing with the climate
change as it falls out by the way we
have been lowering our climate emissions
in the united states with more efficient
forms of energy like nuclear and natural
gas both of which are opposed by the
democratic party
this bill by the way not only spends
money on sort of random stuff it also
includes more affordable housing
investments in technology and climate
change research as well as potentially
lowering the medicare eligibility age
lowering the medica that's what we need
we need more systemic debt that's going
to make things all better but again
climate change this is where they're
putting all their focus is in the
climate change stuff right schumer
doubled down on this he says the budget
bill is going to be chiefly about
combating climate change that's the big
push because that's the big emergency
the budget reconciliation bill will do
more to combat climate change than any
legislation ever
ever in the history of the senate that
is a promise
and while my republican colleagues
regurgitate the same tired talking
points about a democratic spending spree
let me remind america that we plan to
pay for this package by making the
wealthy pay their fair share okay you're
not paying for any of this every
democratic proposal here does not pay
for itself okay barack
i keep saying barack obama because joe
biden is essentially obama's third turn
joe biden's plan to pay for this with
taxes does not wash he has charted his
tax increases over the course of 15
years he has charted his spending
increases over the course of eight to 10
years that does not work okay the taxes
have to occur in the same period as the
spending
he's not doing that and char and by the
way taxing the rich ain't gonna pay for
it either you're gonna have to find
other ways of raising that money he
knows that all the democrats know that
but they don't care if they can just
scare the hell out of you with climate
change then they will
and here's the thing there is
the the most alarmist climate
predictions are just flat wrong the most
alarmist climate predictions are not
rooted in reality the reality according
to the international
panel on climate change the
intergovernmental panel on climate
change the ipcc which is sort of the
supposed gold standard for this stuff
the ipcc is now sounding more and more
rational on the issue saying that
long-term climate change is a problem
but it is not an existential threat to
humanity nor is it likely to kill
millions of human beings the way the
democrats say it will
in fact let's go through that for just a
second so
over the course of this week the ipcc
rolled out its brand new climate change
report it's this brand new magical
climate change report okay they rolled
one out a couple of years ago and it's
important to go through the details
because the headlines on this thing suck
okay the headlines on on the climate
change panel decision the the ipcc new
paper are just
they're so over the top and insane that
if you don't know anything and if you
don't read the background paper you end
up freaking out
it's things like
extreme weather events likely to kill
millions
it's all this talk about how the climate
is going to the world will boil we're
all going to die millions will perish in
the flames
okay but that's not correct
okay so let's begin with a couple of
simple facts
and when it comes to natural disasters
killing human beings
the simple fact is
that the global annual death rate from
natural disasters
has been dropping precipitously
from the 1960s on
okay this is a chart from our world in
data
and it shows the annual death rates from
natural disasters per 100 000 as of the
1920s
there were 22 deaths per 100 000 from
drought
and they're probably another four or
five
deaths per 100 000 from earthquake you
had a bunch of people dying from storms
you had a few people dying from extreme
temperatures
and then you can see a precipitous drop
from the 30s 40s 50s 60s 70s 80s 90s all
the way down to from around 28 people
dying per 100 000 from natural disasters
in the 1920s all the way down to in the
1990s less than two people per 100 000
on the planet
dying from natural disasters as of the
2010s we're still below two we're still
in the one area one out of a hundred
thousand people
okay so we've reduced deaths from
natural disasters by a factor of
somewhere between 25 and 30 over the
course of the last century
okay there there are declining deaths
from floods in europe for example same
sort of thing right the number of people
who are dying in floods
are it's just way way lower than it ever
has been
okay and yet the idea here is that we
are going to boil the earth millions
will die if not thousands millions will
die it's going to be worse than cobit i
mean chuck schumer says it's going to be
worse than covid
okay but that's just not true in fact
even the ipcc has started to hedge its
bets so there are few things you should
know about these ipcc reports one is
that the ipcc reports include ranges of
possibilities
one of the ranges of possibilities used
in the current ipcc report is the least
likely scenario ever
okay that is what they call the rcp 8.5
or the ssp5 to 8.5 okay that would be
the scenario in which we basically
double our emissions over the course of
the next couple of decades who thinks
that global emissions are going to
double over the course of the next
couple of decades does anyone think that
that we're going to double our coal
emission coal emissions here in the
united states
and globally does anybody actually think
that
the answer of course is no that's not
going to happen
okay the the the ipcc presents that
possibility as feasible for purposes of
scaring the living hell out of you
we are not going to double our carbon
emissions
that's very very silly in fact even the
ipcc recognizes that 8.5 scenarios have
a quote-unquote low likelihood but then
they remain neutral
with respect to which scenario they're
assuming is going to take place
in fact there's a guy named roger pilkey
he does good work on this a professor in
colorado
and uh and he points out
that the ipcc report focuses
disproportionately on the 8.5 scenario
in order to scare the living hell out of
you in fact of all the mentions in the
report from the ipcc
42 percent of all mentions
mention the least likely scenario the
rcp 8.5 so they lay out essentially like
five or six scenarios
the most likely scenario by their
sort of math is the scenario in which
the climate changes between 2 and 4.5
degrees over the course of the next
century
there are very few scenarios in which
the climate changes on an average 8.5
degrees celsius over the cour over the
next century that's just not going to
happen
okay which is really
like so it's absurd that they even put
that in the report and then it's even
more absurd that they spend so much time
focusing in on the report
okay but even the ipcc
recognizes the the variability in their
predictions so when they make findings
in the ipcc report and i know nobody
reads below the top line you just read
the story of the daily mail that freaks
you out about global warming but when
you read below the top line what you'll
see is that the ipcc makes a series of
predictions those predictions are
gradated right some will be
characterized as very likely
or likely or more likely than not
most of these ones most of the ones you
will see are likely
right which can range all the way from
66 to 100 percent that's a pretty broad
range of possibility in other words we
we think we're right here and there's
like a two and three chance we're right
anywhere from two and three to like a
hundred percent well that's a pretty big
possibility of missing is it not
okay that's that's the term you see a
lot in these sorts of reports is likely
or medium confidence
the more extreme the prediction the less
confidence they have
and in fact the ipcc report points out
for example
that the frequency and intensity of
heavy precipitation for example
have increased at a global scale
it's likely likely precipitation has
increased at a global scale thanks to
climate change
meaning like
two and three chance that that's
happening
then they'll also acknowledge by the way
that heavy precipitation meaning a lot
of rain does not mean
more flooding per se
okay also
they do note for example that when it
comes to tropical cyclones that they
have no predictions
they say that we actually don't have any
trends in tropical cyclones like we we
have no clue whether tropical cyclones
are getting more common or
not i mean like there's a lot of
uncertainty in other words about the
amount of damage to be done here
and most of the stuff is baked into the
cake so when it comes to what we can do
the answer typically is we mitigate
right huge swaths of very populous
countries including countries that exist
in for example scandinavian countries
exist under the water level under the
water table okay that means that they're
living you know with they have locks and
canals right this is true in the
netherlands for example
and they're fine right human beings are
extremely good at adapting but the goal
here for the democratic party is to
scare the hell out of you so they hope
you don't look at the report they hope
that you don't see that there's a wide
variety of variables they hope that you
go to the most extreme possible scenario
in your head
and so when you hear that the world is
getting warmer you think oh man
wildfires drought everybody dying of
starving okay by the way many many more
people like a multiple of people on
planet earth die of cold than die of
heat
so actually a number of lives will
actually be saved by this if you're more
worried about people dying of cold then
of heat which is what you should be
statistically speaking but again it's
all about the crisis mentality if you
push the crisis mentality then you can
get people to do what you want them to
do
and it was a foregone conclusion of
course they were going to move with
climate change as their next big crisis
alrighty we will be back here later
today with an additional hour of the ben
shapiro show coming up soon is the matt
wall show it airs at 1 30 pm eastern be
sure to check it out over at
dailywire.com i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliott feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pablo
wydowski associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sciovitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica kranz the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
john bickley here daily wire editor in
chief wake up every morning with our new
show morning wire on today's episode
pressure ramps up on governor cuomo to
resign the aclu is suing the biden
administration and fake vaccination
cards are on the rise join us and get
the facts first on the news you need to
know with our show morning wire